if you buy a clock like this one that
says radio controlled you just put a
battery in and it sets itself to the
correct time and it stays there
automatically for a year or more so it
come to receiving signals from
satellites and there's no Wi-Fi
connection there's nowhere near enough
power in here for any of that instead it
uses much older technology here at the
radio transmission station in anthon the
National physical laboratory npl
broadcasts a Time signal out to the UK
in a simple enough format that the cheap
electronics inside this clock can
understand it and run accurately for
over a year on a single double A battery
under npl's base in London I asked their
team how it all works what we have in
Anton are some very high-end cesium
atomic clocks like the ones we have down
here we broadcast from there we monitor
the signals at npl and accordingly put
out stairs to those clocks to correct
for any
any change because it's a very low
frequency 60 kilohertz well it has very
low susceptibility to atmospheric
effects we steer from npl based on
measuring what Anton is broadcasting at
the level of nanoseconds that is the
nanosecond the distance light travels in
one nanosecond 30 centimeters
all that is taken into account so that
seems simple enough the official time
scale is kept in London I wasn't allowed
anywhere near the official atomic clocks
I don't even know if they're actually at
npl's headquarters or not they might be
somewhere else they told me nothing but
up north here this transmitter has
separate atomic clocks about 400
kilometers away from the base or 1.4
light milliseconds away because there's
a light speed delay a latency of about a
thousandth of a second between the
transmitter here and the base in London
because the team at npl know exactly
what that delay should be they can issue
Corrections if these clocks start to
drift even by nanoseconds billionths of
seconds officially the accuracy is much
lower than that of course partly because
they keep a very wide safety margin and
partly because I can introduce a one
nanosecond drift to this clock by doing
that what is really important when
you're transferring time is not about
the latency but understanding the
latency so you can take that out of the
equation from the npl we disseminate to
the UK over radio broadcasts essentially
that offers the entire UK menlyn several
milliseconds of traceability to UTC we
also have the fiber delivered service
for a Regulatory Compliance in the
finance sector guaranteed that the
microsecond and that's fine I can
understand all that but then that leads
to another question how does npl know if
their clocks in London start to drift
sure they've got many of them they cross
check and a second in the 21st century
is defined by the number of vibrations
of a cesium atom but still they can't be
perfect they're meant to show the
international standard UTC coordinated
universal time so what if npl's official
source of time keeping truth drifts from
that standard the UTC or coordinate to
Universal town as the name suggests is a
coordinating globally contributing data
from multiple atomic clocks to generate
what is the global time scale UTC
what we have here at npl is the UK's
time scale UTC npl we have a whole Suite
of atomic clocks cesium clocks hydrogen
mazes and our cesium Fountain the Bureau
of weights and measures based in France
take the data from the clouds around the
globe and inform each of the national
lands how offset it is from UTC and
that's where the buck stops in Paris
unless you start getting into physics
and relativity and light cones and
that's way Beyond me why does it matter
well first of all finance and high
frequency trading but also science
things like the square kilometer array
are planet-wide array of radio
telescopes that's being planned and
built right now when they're listening
for incredibly faint radio waves from
space all the telescopes around the
globe have to be synchronized with that
level of precision or the whole
experiment could fall apart so then I
had a final question when accurate time
code is being sent from so many places
when the public can get time that's more
than accurate enough for almost every
purpose from navigation satellites in
space why is this signal still important
and the team from npl had a rather
serious answer time really is is an
invisible utility it's underpins our
digital infrastructure whether it's the
the synchronization of the energy Grid
or the Telecom networks or Finance we
are so dependent on GPS and other
constellations one of the problems we
face is those signals are easily
disrupted it's the equivalent of a light
bulb on the moon one of the things we're
doing at the npl is to ensure that the
UK is resilient for the future
standing by the ocean with a domestic
appliance the weird thing is it's not
the first time